-Our next guest can be seen
this Friday and Saturday
at Laugh Boston.
Please welcome
the very funny Ian Lara!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, hey, hey.
This is very nice.
I'm very excited to be here.
I just celebrated
my 33rd birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Yeah, it's nice.
I'm 33 now.
I'm an adult, you know?
I be doing adult stuff now.
I be reading.
Like, for no reason,
I'll just read, like, to learn.
It's nice.
I was reading a book on TikTok,
and it was talking about...
[ Laughter ]
It was giving advice on how
to be a better adult.
It was like,
"If you're not happy with where
your life is right now,
you need to start manifesting
the things
you want into your life."
Have y'all heard about this?
Manifesting?
[ Crowd cheering ]
Yeah. Women -- they love it.
For the men,
if you never heard about it,
it's this new thing you could do
with all your hopes and dreams.
Remember back in the day
when if you wanted something,
you used to have
to work to get it?
Remember that?
That's completely outdated.
You no longer have to do that.
They've created this new thing.
It's called manifesting.
And the best part about it is,
you don't actually
have to do anything.
You just yell it out in public.
That's it.
That's how I got here.
I just yelled it out
on the train.
"I want to be on
'The Tonight Show,'"
and now I'm here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's great.
It's like a GoFundMe
for the universe.
You just put it out there,
let the world pay for it.
That's if you got
regular dreams, though.
If you got big dreams,
there's another step.
And this is a little
more complex,
because you've got
to get a board.
Y'all heard about
the vision board?
If you never heard,
let me explain.
It's a little more complex,
because you've got
to take a day off work.
You're going to go
to a hardware store.
You're going to ask them
for a board.
They're going to say,
"For what?"
You say, "It's my dreams."
They'll understand.
You're going to take the board,
you drive it home,
you put it on the wall
on top of your bed, right?
Then you've got to step away.
And this is the important part.
Now you need to find
pictures of people
who have achieved the thing
you want to achieve.
People that worked hard
and got after it?
You're going to
find photos of them.
But don't do what they did.
Just the photo. That's enough.
But you can't use the whole
photo, because that's stupid.
You got to cut them out.
And then you put them
on the board,
fill up the board with photos,
and this is very important.
Every night before bed,
you look at it.
Then you can go to sleep.
That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's the best part.
If things don't
work out for you,
you don't got to be embarrassed,
because
if things don't work out,
you can always say this.
You can always say,
"It wasn't meant to be."
And people understand.
It's great.
Being 33 is cool because I still
feel like I'm a young guy,
but I don't like doing
young-guy stuff anymore.
Like, I can no longer
do the random hookups.
Sorry, ladies.
Because I can't spend the night
with women I just met.
I used to do it in my 20s.
I could go out and meet a girl.
We hit it off.
I go back to her place.
I stay the night.
I'll stay the whole weekend.
I ain't have nothing to do.
She used to ask me,
"When you got to go home?"
I'm like, "Thursday.
I'm going to the gym.
After that, I'll come back.
I'm gonna do legs.
Then I'll come back."
Now I can't spend the night
with a stranger.
And it's not even over
anything weird.
It's just I'm 33 now.
I got to worry about sleep.
Once you turn 30,
you don't just lay down
and fall asleep anymore.
You need to create
the perfect environment
for you to get deep rest.
Those are my
dating questions now.
What kind of mattress you got?
You got the blackout curtains?
100%?
No sunlight in the morning?
That's sexy.
That's who I am now.
I've had beautiful women
invite me over,
but I take a look at them
and I'm like,
"I can tell by your posture
you don't got good pillows.
I need a medium firm
for my lower back, you know?
And do you even have
a white-noise machine
at your house?"
Because I can't go
to sleep to silence, right?
I need sounds.
Can't do silence,
like a murderer.
I need raindrops
if I'mma get rest.
Plus, it's late.
I didn't know this.
You get older, you get mad
when people invite you out late.
You're like, "First of all,
it's already 6:00 p.m.,
and I didn't bring
any melatonin.
And I know you don't have
any because you're 23.
They don't sell them
the 23-year-olds, so..."
Then I was getting worried.
I'm like, "Am I becoming
one of these old weird men?"
Then I had a conversation
with one of my boys,
which, fellas,
that's what you need to do.
Whenever you think
you're getting weird,
talk to your boys, because then
you hear the stuff they do,
and you're like,
"I'm not even that weird."
I was talking to my best friend
about what happened.
I was telling him -- I was like,
"I can't spend the night
with women I just met.
Sometimes, I have
trouble sleeping, you know?
And I don't want her to wake up
in the middle of the night
and turn over -- I'm just up."
These women be watching
these documentaries.
I don't know what's
going through their head.
And he was trying to
relate to me.
He was like,
"No, I know what you mean.
Same thing happened to me.
I was like,
"Oh, yeah? What happened?"
He was like, "One time, I was
hooking up with this girl.
Middle of the night,
I accidentally took a dump
in her plants."
I was like,
"That's not what I mean."
I thought I misunderstood.
I said, "Hold on.
You actually
went in her plants?"
He was like,
"You know how that go."
I was like, "No.
Don't include me in this."
Ladies, you ever wondered why
some men are so confident
and where that comes from?
This is where. I'll tell you.
We have conversations
with our boys.
They'll tell us stuff like that.
We'll be like,
"Okay, I don't do that.
Maybe I'm God's gift to women.
Is that it? Am I the best man
on the planet?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then you go home
with confidence.
You get into an argument
with your lady,
she threaten to leave you,
but you ain't worried.
You already know
what's out there.
You're like,
"Where you gonna go?
Find a man that's going to
ruin your plants?
You don't even know what
you got. You ungrateful, okay?
You need me. I'm potty-trained.
You manifested this, remember?"
I'm Ian Lara.
Y'all been great. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on, brother.
-Appreciate it.
-Always. Thank you, buddy.
Ian Lara! Ian Lara!
See Ian this Friday
and Saturday at Laugh Boston.
We'll be right back, everybody.